[Music]
you can take some robots take some smart
people and engineers and make something
really nice and work quickly and
efficiently especially in the multi
robot space the problem is that doesn't
generalize well so if suppose you got
two robots that coordinate very well and
do this whole thing very nicely maybe
add another robot the whole plan will
break and this work tries to pose the
problem in a more general framework that
given what we call macro actions you
could use the planner that we have to go
out and solve a problem so this was an
instance of a multi agent planning
problem that involved a peer to robot
and then we also had two turtle BOTS and
there are waiters the turtle BOTS cannot
communicate with one another unless
there are nearby and the turtle BOTS
don't know if someone's going to want to
place an order when they go to the room
or not the turtle BOTS also don't know
what the other two robots doing one way
you can try to reduce the problem is
using what are called macro actions and
the macro actions they can be described
in a general way of just like what their
effects are and so when you do that you
can cover up a lot of details and trying
to coordinate the behavior between the
robots you would like to just say okay
that one go to everyone and that one get
a drink you don't want to actually be
thinking about the navigation problems
the turtle BOTS started out in a
location and they immediately looked at
what they should do from there like
what's the macro action so it would go
inside a room and ask like do you want
to order a drink
the student had to say yes by toggling
the button
if they didn't the turtlebot assumed
they did not want to drink so the
observation it would get inside of room
would be I'm in this room and there's a
drink order or there's not a drink order
if the turtlebot went to the pr2 and got
a drink it's a new observation would be
that it's holding good drink if both of
the robots were in the bar that's when
they had that limited communication
where they could detect if one of the
turtle BOTS was being served by the pr2
and so if that was the case they would
go and do a different macro action
there's two phases in this process the
first part is offline
and in the offline process you are
thinking about all of these problems of
how are you going to get the robots to
coordinate their actions given that you
know they won't be able to communicate
all the time given that you know they
won't have knowledge about the whole
world where other robots are so when
you're creating a plan for each of the
robots to be running individually that's
when you reason about all these things
and then when you're actually executing
these controllers you don't think about
any of those sort of things
you
[Music]